der innenminister horst seehofer hat er
gestern außerdem angekündigt gegen eine
autorin der berliner tageszeitung taz
anklage zu erstatten seehofer bringt den
text der kolumnistin mit der gewalt von
stuttgart in verbindung
in dem artikel geht es darum wo
polizisten arbeiten könnten wenn die
polizei abgeschafft werden würde
der kapitalismus aber nicht daran würde
die mülldeponie als einzige plausible
option genannt dazu hieß es polizisten
könnten hier unter ihresgleichen
arbeiten
csu-innenexperte michael kupfer und
lehrbeauftragte für gefahrenabwehr recht
an der uni hamburg hat gestern gesagt
die stuttgarter gewaltexzesse zeigen
welche üblen folgen pauschale polizei
shelter haben kann er ist mir nun
zugeschaltet ergo war schönen guten
morgen
finden sie es richtig dass horst
seehofer die autorin an zeigt ja es ist
richtig dass er weiter zu verfolgen das
klima so nicht auf sich beruhen lassen
was in diesem artikel die ich jetzt
meine anführungsstrichen setzen passiert
ist es eine eine menschenverachtende und
im übrigen gruppenbezogene furchtbare
herabsetzung und ausgrenzung der
polizisten
das ist die entmenschlichung der polizei
und so etwas kann man nicht als
journalistische freiheit oder gar
vielleicht am ende noch als satire
durchgehen lassen
wir haben auch die journalisten eine
verantwortung zu tragen und die ist in
diesem fall mit füßen getreten worden
und es ist richtig dass man das auch der
juristischen klärung zuführen wie wohl
dazu sagen das ist keine vorverurteilung
aber dass die ermittlungsbehörden und
gegebenenfalls sich die gerichte damit
beschäftigen wie sie in diesem fall
sicher richtig
er guckt jetzt will ich mal aus dem
fenster lehnen und sagen dass nicht alle
täter in stuttgart diesen artikel aus
der taz gelesen haben
wenn sie mir da zustimmen würde gerne
von ihnen wissen wie es dann doch zu
diesen riesigen gewaltexzessen gekommen
sein konnte
also selbstverständlich ist es so dass
ein haufen durchgeknallter gewalttäter
wie wir sie in stuttgart gelesen haben
vermutlich nicht alles lesen sind
das würde auch die diskussion sicher zu
sehr verkürzt das wäre mir zu sehr
schwarz weiß aber richtig ist es doch
trotzdem dass mit solchen artikeln ich
sage es noch mal mit der menschlichen
der polizei kann auch zusätzlich frage
stellen wie intelligent ist es darüber
zu sinnieren was passiert wenn die
polizei abgeschafft würde also was ist
das denn schon gedanke und wie hinzu
kommen der anmoderation beziehungsweise
in der diskussion davor angeklungen wenn
dann beiträge eben aus den politischen
spitzenpersonal wie von westen kommen
die dann einen pauschalverdacht einen
generalverdacht über polizisten aus
kippen
das ist das klima das dann am ende
solche taten begünstigt nochmal das ist
sicherlich nicht die einzige ursache
aber es ist ein klima bei dem sich täter
wie in stuttgart berechtigt fühlen und
berechtigt gefühlt haben sich mit einem
straftäter oder mit einer person in
einer kontrolle unterzogen worden ist zu
solidarisieren und dabei am ende
brutalste gewalt auszuüben wenn sie
jetzt schon die politiker ansprechen was
muss ich dann in der politik ganz
konkret ändern um solche gewaltexzesse
in zukunft auf jeden fall zu unterbinden
also wir müssen in der politik auf jeden
fall acht geben dass wir also ich sags
mal so die schleichende aber gezielte
verschiebung des diskurses in den
letzten jahren wird die damit zu tun hat
dass debatten im deutschen bundestag
beispielsweise verfassungsfeindliche
organisationen wie die antifa von
einzelnen rednern vor allem von der
linken teils von den grünen glorifiziert
werden dass damit integriert wird es
gebe eine unterscheidung zwischen guter
und schlechter gewalt diese theorie ist
übrigens das absolut toxische am
linksextremismus davon auszugehen dass
es eine gute gewalt gibt die für eine
gute sache streitet und in diesem
diskurs müssen wir ganz fein achtgeben
dass da von einzelnen personen nicht die
falsche schlüsse gezogen werden
insoweit haben wir als politik eine frau
in ordnung das heißt nicht dass wir
nicht offen diskutieren das ist übrigens
auch nicht mehr petitum die dinge müssen
sie offen diskutieren und dabei gibt es
ein breites spektrum unterschiedlichster
meinungen aber wenn man auf der
bundespolitischen bühne oder im
deutschen bundestag dinge sagt dann muss
aber auch klar sein welche
öffentlichkeit das hat und da muss man
seine worte dann schon mit bedacht
werden